mes chers amis
c'est avec beaucoup de bonheur et du
fond du cœur que je souhaite ce soir à
la veille de ce début de cette année
nouvelle vous présenter mes vœux les
plus personnels les plus chaleureux les
plus sincères pour chacune et chacun
d'entre vous pour vous militants des
républicains pour vous bien au-delà qui
avait la France chevillée au cœur et au
corps je veux vous souhaiter le meilleur
je veux que l'épanouissement le bonheur
personnel soit au rendez-vous de toutes
vos espérances au cours de cette année
et puis je souhaite de façon plus
collective que 2023 soit l'année d'une
nouvelle espérance que 2023 soit le
socle de se redressement dont notre pays
attend besoin autour des valeurs autour
des convictions celle de la droite
républicaine celle des républicains que
depuis tant d'années fort de notre
histoire fort nos racines fort de notre
culture nous portons avec détermination
et combativité bien sûr les raisons
d'être un pessimistes sont nombreuses
nos services publics n'ont jamais été
aussi affaiblis nos forces de l'ordre
n'ont jamais été au stand attaqués nos
comptes publics n'ont jamais été autant
dégradé votre pouvoir d'achat n'a jamais
été autant fragilisé notre industrie n'a
jamais été autant déstabilisé nos
services publics ceux de la santé ceux
de l'école sont aujourd'hui frappés par
une forme de déclin que certains
considèrent comme irréversibles et bien
face à cette déchéance face à ce déclin
face à cette dégradation qui trop
souvent frappe notre pays je vous
appelle au sursaut et je veux
qu'ensemble nous port sursaut que nous
portions avec courage avec détermination
une volonté pour nourrir cette espérance
je veux que nous soyons le parti de la
réforme que nous portions une grande
politique de baisse massive des impôts
que nous soyons le parti qui habite le
travail que nous soyons le parti qui
réinstalle l'ordre républicain au cœur
de notre pacte social je veux que l'on
puisse choisir demain qu'il en accueille
sur le territoire national je veux qu'on
puisse à cela transmettre notre histoire
notre culture notre identité sans
qu'elle soit dénaturées déconstruite
c'est tout cela que je vous propose pour
porter ensemble en 2023 cette nouvelle
espérance tous ensemble avec l'équipe
qui va m'entourer en ce début d'année
2023 nous allons bâtir rebâtir une
grande informations politiques modernes
ouvertes sur tous les enjeux de la
société sur ce notamment du défi
climatique sur ce des enjeux de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse sur
ceux d'une économie qui retrouve sa
compétitivité sur ce d'un pays qui
protège ses enfants des menaces qui se
multiplient c'est tout cela qu'ensemble
nous allons conduire avec beaucoup
d'obstinations avec du courage aussi
dans la fidélité à nos valeurs et nos
idées dans l'indépendance à l'égard de
tous notre histoire nous oblige nous
conduit nous guident pour privilégier
pour préserver comme un joyau cette
indépendance celle que nous ont donné le
général de Gaulle Georges Pompidou
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing Jacques Chirac
Nicolas Sarkozy nous en sommes les
héritiers
ça nous donne plus que jamais des
devoirs ces devoirs je veux avec vous
les assumer à chaque instant de cette
année nouvelle au service du
redressement de la France très bel année
à chacune et à chacun très bel année à
la France